[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tony bacelli former jacksonville jaguar
and maybe will live to see the day when
he gets into the hall of fame
five pro bowls he's the lead analyst for
thursday night football in westwood one
and he does the jags
radio color uh analyst and uh part of
westwood ones the nfl
playoff coverage he's gonna be there for
the buccaneers and the saints that'll be
sunday night tony joins us on the
program
how does this go right for urban meyer
in jacksonville tony
well that's easy dan you know that win
games winning solves everything i mean
it literally cures
every ale of a professional sports team
and
an athlete and i think the point is is
is
your comments earlier were dead on the
transition is littered
from college to the nfl with dead bodies
of guys who could not do it um now
i think what shad khan decided was we
need to do something different this has
been a franchise over the last 10 years
that has not been relevant outside of
2017
where they made an afc uh championship
run and so i think he wanted somebody
who was a proven winner
um who was a proven leader and gave them
a chance to kind of make a splash day
one
but also had instant credibility when he
walked in the room and so
um listen he's a leader he's won
everywhere he's ever been
and the one thing i do like about his
kind of philosophy
and and because i'm a believer of it
it's not about
what scheme you run it's not about hey i
run the gap or i run the zone or i blitz
i do
this i mean everyone's doing the same
thing you know with a different
variation it's about getting the right
people in the building
and so the question i have is is can you
build the right staff
can you get the right oc the right dc
the right assistance
and then and then what is your player
procurement strategy because getting
guys who fit
what you want to do and i think that's
where teams fail and that's where
organizations in the nfl who really
struggle is you don't have the pieces
that fit what you're trying to do
and that'll be interesting to see the uh
who he surrounds himself with
but as a leader dan it's unquestionable
he's got it done
but also relating to these players we we
find that that there is a gap
in college you listen to me in the nfl
it feels like
you listen to your players and and maybe
i'm overstating it here
but you know what what is going to be
the biggest
difference in the transition of coaching
college players
to coaching nfl players well the good
thing if you're coaching the jags it's
not much different than college right
now because
they're so dang young so it will
probably work
um i mean listen the big difference is
you have guys who are in their 30s have
kids families been married for a while
and everything else
but i think the one thing is even in
college today dan
these are millennials and so the
millennials don't want to you to tell
them
what to do and they don't buy into that
you have to be able to build
relationships with players
whether it's college or pro i'm a big
believer in that and guys want to know
why are you asking him to do something
and i think urban's smart enough i mean
he's been around calls he understands
that he understood recruiting
and i think it's similar to in today's
player they want a relationship they
want to know you care about them and
they want to know why you're asking to
do something so
whether you're hard or you're not player
coach
not a players coach both can work um
and so but really where you get to buy
in is one
you have credibility day one but then
what you institute
leads to success so ultimately he's
gonna have to win football games to get
the credibility he wants long term
there was an article in the orlando
sentinel in early december calling for
the jags to hire you as the general
manager
have you been approached to be the
general manager
dan my phone never rang once so that if
that gives you any insight on
whether i've been asked or not not even
once not even like an accidental like
the wrong
call wrong number maybe the wrong number
yeah wrong number hey we're trying to
get so
no uh listen my role uh my role is the
uh i do the team i do the uh obviously
the radio you talked about it
i i've been there since day one love the
organization
want nothing but the success um happy to
give input where i'm asked but my job
isn't to
give input how about offensive line
coach
um again if urban would love to i will
talk
to anyone about any opportunity but
right now there's no plans and
my phone's not ringing and i'm very
satisfied and happy with what i do
on a daily basis if urban did not have
the number one pick
would he be taking this jacksonville job
it's a great question um
i don't know because if you look at it
yes they have the number one pick
let's say they would have the number two
pick you're still going to get a really
good player there's
you know you have justin fields who's a
good player i think that zach wilson is
intriguing out of byu so you can still
get your quarterback
what doesn't change regardless of the
draft pick is this team
is going to have over 100 million
dollars of cap space in a year
where a lot of teams are gonna be
struggling i think there's a lot of good
players out there
to go get uh and so i don't think any
nothing changes
in that world and also the other thing i
think one of the reasons urban came here
dan
is he can do something no one's ever
done in jackson before and he can make
it relevant he can
you know win a super bowl he can be the
guy who does it
and urban's a competitive individual
he's a guy who wants to
you know make a name and be out there
and do something no one else can do
and he has a chance to do that and with
the jaguar so i think he probably would
have still just because there's so many
other positives around it but i think
that
maybe that was the tipping point yeah i
just wonder long term
you know that that would be a question
that's that's my question with urban i
don't think anybody is going to
uh critique his credentials but just his
mental and physical health and being
able to do this a grind man
this is yeah college is one thing pros
this is day and night grind and
i don't know yeah i'll say this dancing
college
it's you know the first two places that
bowling green in utah he had to build
that he's competing he didn't have the
best players i mean
he proved that he can do it florida
state in ohio i mean excuse me florida
and ohio state
he woke up day one with a team that was
better than
nine eight to ten teams that were on a
schedule i mean he was just better they
drive
recruited better than everything else
that's not the case in the nfl and so it
is that grind and so
people ask me what i think about it i
said all the things i said positive a
second ago here's my question and i'll
maybe articulate it similar to what you
said maybe a little different
is um he's never done the nfl so we know
about that there's history we can look
at and kind of make our judgment
the health is real um this is an
individual at two different spots
because of the grind and what went on
at florida and ohio state that had to
step away for health reasons
and i hate it for him because no one
wants to have those things and so you
worry and i think as an owner you look
back
and i think when you make that decision
you have to do your homework and say
okay how are you physically what does it
look like how do you manage that
um because you you're making the hire
for the long term and you want him to
build
something um that is sustainable so um
that's something to watch i know every
jag fan will probably have
be praying for them and making sure that
health doesn't become an issue
but it's hard to avoid because the
mental grind and fatigue
um and especially when you're wired like
urban meyer from what i've been told
i've never met him but i've been told
he's a competitive dude
and winning is the only option and in
the nfl you're gonna lose some games so
that'll be something to watch but
hopefully if you're a jags fan hopefully
you don't have to deal with it very much
so that means you're winning a lot of
football games tony biselli joining us
he's the color
analyst for the jacksonville jaguars
also works for westwood one and
of course former jags offensive lineman
speaking of which
the first thing i would do is not repeat
the mistake that the colts did with
andrew luck
i would make sure i had a really good
offensive line
because the colts did it in the
reverse order and then all of a sudden
they wake up one day and they go wait
andrew luck doesn't want to play anymore
no he got so banged up through those
first couple of years
now they have a great offensive line
that's what i hope that
the jags invest in if you got trevor
lawrence i can't have
a 100 million dollar quarterback and
i've got you know pennies on the dollar
at the offensive line positions here
tone
yeah i don't think i mean listen my
formula to build a football team is not
that complicated you got to have a
quarterback i mean there's no doubt
about that and
you're hoping trevor lawrence is that
guy after that dan you better protect
the quarterback
if you can't control the line of
scrimmage by running it when you have to
and protecting the quarterback i don't
think you can
be effective long-term i think you're
going to struggle so you have to invest
there uh for the jaguars good news is
they got
three guys in the interior pretty good
uh norwell is a good player
he missed a couple games because his
injuries but the last three years he's
played good football
aj can the right guard had re-signed
last year his best year football was
really good brandon linder's
upper echelon center uh where they need
to improve and they need to
do a little bit we're at the tackle
positions juwan taylor is a second year
player out of florida
uh has high potential he's going to be
your right tackle next year the question
is that left tackle
cam robinson out of alabama a four-year
guy he's a free agent
do you do you sign him he was better
this year
uh needs to improve do you sign him and
make him your left tackle or do you go
draft
or go in free agency and say hey let's
go get a rental out of trent williams
who's a free agent out of san francisco
and maybe ask pay him more money
than anyone else to get him come in so
you are dead on though
um the number one job of the gm and
urban meyer i think especially early is
if you're going to draft trevor lawrence
surround him
with people starting with the offensive
line where he can have success
you were there when the browns beat the
steelers
and a lot of times you can tell before a
game
when teams walk on the field like
there's confidence there
the first time i ever saw it was when
the raiders beat the redskins in the
super bowl when marcus allen had that
unbelievable run
like the raiders came on the field and
if i
could have put my house up if i had a
house i would have bet the raiders
that night i don't know if you noticed
anything different with
it felt like and i've said this before
and my audience is tired of hearing
about it
cleveland knew their identity going into
that game
and the steelers did not i don't know if
you sensed that at all
but the browns looked like a different
team
than earlier in the year against
pittsburgh why
yeah it's so hard dan in this cove does
it get a real sense number one
you can't go down the field and spend
time with the teams and get a feel and
get the emotion and kind of
have conversations too there's no fans
and so it's almost it's a very sterile
environment
i mean think of how different that game
would have been if you had a packed
house
um at heinz field with the places going
crazy um but
and i think also you probably got that
feeling because right when it started
boy the snap over the head and next
thing you know this thing's out of
control so
um and there was a desperation on on the
cleveland sideline like hey chip on the
shoulder we have something to prove and
it almost got the feeling like
pittsburgh's like we always beat the
browns
you know it's in pittsburgh we never
lose to them so what's going to change
this year
what do you got going on there my
computer's going crazy
i'm trying to throw it off you know what
it could be urban meyer
asking you to be offensive oh no okay
all right dan i'll text you if i hear
okay
i appreciate that uh would you rather
pass block for brady or breeze
um tom brady because i think tom brady
is one of the best
um pocket quarterbacks i've ever seen
his movement in the pocket buying time
and he's a tackle's best friend because
he always steps up he's always working
up in the
pocket meaning it helps you with your
angles and and your ability to protect
them breeze is good too
i mean they're both fabulous in the
pocket you don't play this long if you
can't operate from the pocket
um but if you if i have to choose one uh
it's tom brady
plus as i'm six seven he's six four
probably easier for him to see over on
top of me
this game will come down to what um
can the uh can the buccaneers run the
ball yeah um you look at the 38 three
game
they went their pass happy byron left
which i don't think he was his best game
he called
they got away from it and over 35 of the
time
the saints were pressuring tom brady or
they're hitting them and they had no
rhythm
you got to get leonard fournette you got
to get ronald jones they don't have to
be you know they don't have to be the
tennessee titans with derrick henry or
the baltimore baltimore ravens running
the ball but they gotta
you know they at least have to threaten
the saints defense
to give brady time to operate uh and to
throw the ball around
good to talk to you as always tony
thanks for joining us have fun on uh
sunday night
thanks dan talk to you soon that's tony
beselni
does the uh color for uh radio on jags
radio network now beyond westwood won
their nfl playoff coverage he's got
buccaneer saints
on sunday night